Has your love life been stuck in a rut lately?
Maybe you should spice it up with a stay at
a motel, hotel...
Hey lovers Julia here for DNews
Before we dive into learning about spicing
up your love life with vacation sex, if you’re
new here, please take a moment to subscribe
so you can get new science content every day
of the week and helps us know you guys are
watching!
So, it’s no secret that after a while, sometimes
love loses it’s spark. Couples get stressed
and busy and sex just doesn’t seem to be
a priority any more. Some might turn to expert
advice, a sex therapist might tell you to
try new things or get away for some quality
time. But, simple hotel sex might be just
what the doctor ordered.
According to a 2004 National Leisure Travel
Monitor study, one third of couples reported
they had more sex while on vacation. So clearly
people are already taking advantage of a little
get away!
So what is about a hotel that gets people
all hot and heavy?
Well for one it sets the mood. A hotel room,
could ease stress. Psychotherapist Ian Kerner
says getting out of the house might be away
to leave all your cares behind literally.
In a hotel, there’s no distractions or reminders
of life’s daily stressors. No bills to be
paid, no laundry thrown all over the floor.
He told the Huffington Post that in a hotel
“you’re in a place out of time, out of
your life” and this “creates a boundary
[between yourself] and anxiety and stressors
of everyday life, [which] is going to contribute
to sexual arousal."
And he’s not the psychologist who thinks
a get away is a good idea. Participating in
a new experience with your loved one can bring
back that old spark in other ways. Social
Psychologist Dr. Arthur Aron, believes that
when couples are first in love they stay up
all night learning about each other. This
facilitates what’s called self expansion,
when you include the other person as part
of yourself. That buzz wears off after while,
but Aron told the New York Times that he thinks
“couples can get some of that back by doing
challenging and exciting things together.”
But don’t just take psychologist's word
for it. Your brain thinks so too. Sex in a
new environment is definitely a change of
pace, and the sheer novelty of the situation
may help bring back the spark!
We are wired to get a kick out of new things,
new things help improve memory and learning.
And one study published in the journal Neuron
found out how. In a cleverly designed study,
the researchers found that new photos participants
had never seen before activated the midbrain,
but the photos they had seen did not. The
midbrain is part of our brain's reward system.
Specifically the substantia nigra/ventral
tegmental area, is responsible for a lot of
our motivations and rewards, but it also plays
a role in dopamine production. So, basically,
the researchers found that experiencing novelty
effects dopamine levels. And this hit of dopamine
makes us feel pretty good for evolutionary
reasons. The researchers said that "Seeking
new and unfamiliar experiences is a fundamental
behavioural tendency in humans and animals”.
And if you remember some earlier DNews episodes,
you might know that dopamine is often called
the pleasure hormone, since it’s released
during pleasurable experiences like eating
sweets and yes sex. We get little rewards
when we do certain things that benefit us.
Dopamine is a complex neurotransmitter, and
it does more than just reward us, it also
drives our desires and it’s released with
the anticipation of a pleasurable experience,
even if that experience never happens. Anticipation
can be pleasurable all on it's own. So, a
new experience with your loved one might prime
the brain for a pleasurable experience to
come.
So get your of your relationship rut and go
check into the nearest hotel and get your
love on!
Sex is such a huge part of the human experience,
heck it’s a huge part of the experience
of all life. But why?
Why do we have sex at all?
Trace has the answer in this video, right
here.